tras una larga espera una disculpa
histórica el papá francisco pidió perdón
por los abusos cometidos por la iglesia
católica en los internados de canadá
donde más de 150.000 niños indígenas
fueron arrancados a sus familias para
ser asimilados por la fuerza a la
cultura europea
por la deplorable conducta de los
miembros de la iglesia católica pido
perdón a dios y quiero decirles de todo
corazón que estoy herido y me uno a mis
hermanos obispos canadienses para
pedirles disculpas estos comentarios se
produjeron después de que una delegación
de líderes indígenas y supervivientes de
los internados viajará a italia para
reunirse con el papá
hoy es un día que hemos estado esperando
y cuando digo nosotros me refiero a
nuestra familia a todas las personas que
se quedaron atrás y sin duda es un día
que pasará a la historia
la disculpa que hemos recibido hoy es
absolutamente histórica y muy
significativa para mucha gente nos
permite seguir avanzando en el camino de
la curación y continuar nuestra lucha
por la acción entre cuatro mil y seis
mil niños murieron en esos internados
mientras que otros sufrieron abusos
psicológicos
físicos y sexuales
una comisión federal de investigación
concluyó en 2015 que el sistema
equivalía a un genocidio cultural los
líderes indígenas han pedido a la
iglesia católica y al gobierno federal
que hagan públicos todos los registros
sobre los internados mientras que las
comunidades siguen buscando justicia